thank you alejandro yes indeed we are
with a very happy winner of the round
darius wiertz uh darius first of all
congratulations it was kind of a
balanced event up until the last two
rounds after that back-to-back victories
how does that feel yeah it feels amazing
to win last two games of course and uh
yeah it was overall a great tournament i
think uh for me my result wise
i miss plus two in such a strong field
is
it's a big achievement i think
some small games some lucky games so
yeah overall i'm happy with my result
maybe a bit topsy-turvy up until today's
game today it felt quite smooth take us
through the critical moments sure
and we are right here
uh all right so e4
sc5 yeah so i like surprise move g6 i
was expecting only five my prep which is
what alex played against jeffrey
and i prepared something there
so but gcses came as a surprise and uh
i didn't want to play d4 because uh
i
like mostly mauro's stuff
and here i'm not getting it so i decided
to just play bishop b5 so he tracked me
with this move order just pretty smart
uh yeah now e5 and uh so here i just
played a3 knight seven bishop c4 so i
wasted the tempo because i don't really
really want to take on c6 but
because bc and i'm not getting anything
and bishop b54 is like a waste of a
tempo but anyway i don't think it
matters this much because the character
of the position is pretty
uh
you know
pretty person is pretty calm right
so i don't think it matters much
so yeah d3 d6 here interesting was
bishop g5 but i wasn't sure whether i
need to whether i should trade those
bishop this bishop for tonight
it makes sense of course but i'm not
really sure because main positions just
i need this bishop so i thought that i
would not do it so just play rook b1 h6
fb4
uh
yeah what did he do uh king h7 here
takes takes 95 is pretty normal
b6
and here it was interesting one for b6
that i wanted to play at first rook e1
but then i realized that he has knight
a5 possibly i'm not really sure if it
works but i think it's interesting that
87 knight takes c4
and we do have the end of that game as
roger harshid won his first game of the
tournament
uh good to see him making that final
comeback
uh you were mentioning here knight a5
and the idea is knight x7 knight xc4
and it's getting complicated i take g6
and i think king takes g6 oh my goodness
okay you take c4 queen takes d1 rook
takes d1 and my pawn structure is pretty
bad and i think it's important with the
king because he has always uh
f5 ideas and finn's compensation pretty
much like let's say bishop e6 or
something i i'm not really sure also
important that we should be two has f6
always so he always has some
conversation here on the search
structure that's why it's important to
take the king you know with that pawn
because he has f6 in that case the d5
pawn would be too weak in that case
right yeah so but anyway this is just
kind of small numbers i decided to take
queen 7 bishop d5 is all normal b1
uh rook c8 bishop d2 queen d6 yeah here
i like c4 uh installs bishop on d5 i
mean security usually free
yeah g5 and this will surprise me a
little bit uh i didn't expect it i don't
know what else he could do but this move
surprised me a little bit um queen c2 uh
g6 yeah and here i wasn't sure if g3 is
the right move or not i thought maybe 92
knight f4 knight f1 or something but on
the other hand like i didn't want to get
this knight to f4 but probably just
didn't really matter anyway g3 uh
well he went back 97 the queen b2 f6
knight d2 i want to bring my knight to
e3 ideally but it's not so easy because
if i play another one he has a f5 or
something
yeah he wants to break up in that
structure he wants to play breakout
break up the center of f5 ideally or or
b5 like uh sort of almost happen in the
game
uh but
yeah i that's why i played rook e2 to
sort of make prophylaxis against this
and here my small trick was that after
queen c2 he plays b5 right now
i wanted to play d4
and if ede5 wins
and if cdb should be four also wins i
believe
ah so that's a very picturesque move
yeah
that's what it is that's pretty clever
yeah but but he played with a6 which i
guess he did not see d4 idea but then i
started thinking about this and after
his d4 i wasn't sure what's going on
through city city xd4
uh bishop b4 and queen c7 bishop b7 rook
e8 bishop before a5
this one yeah yes
before and a5 and bishop is getting
trapped of course position is i'm not
worth there but i wasn't sure who
benefits from all this stuff or maybe i
missed something here in this position
but i think i should be still better but
uh i don't know i just i think anyway i
should have gone for it because i played
this movie one and i keep playing just
king aj so this was kind of unnecessary
i think
i'm cheating because it's like the third
hour commentary
uh
it takes rookie 8
a5
and it it says it actually prefers white
probably bishop c3 bishop c3 or any move
queen knight b3 whatever what's the
evaluation plus 1.2 nothing
yeah i i just wasn't sure because
i just i mean i just want to be sure
yeah so we want king aj and now we got
this position we just play on a couple
of moves and here you got the complicate
somewhere because we played very strong
move a5 and he gets his knight to b4 i
played a4 to stop him from getting b5
but anyway i didn't want him to play b5
so i'd have one on b4 and queen d1 oh
this was a mistake i guess
don't worry too much about it all right
uh
now f5 and i wasn't sure if it takes the
files the right move or not yeah you
have to okay um
takes that i have to take on before
unfortunately now you take the apollo i
think it has to do with the c pawn to
always have some squares was he able to
take on d5 first instead of taking on f5
was that yeah there's also a line but
the knight takes d5 c takes d5
and the thing is that e5 is always weak
yeah this is kind of an issue actually
yeah this is the idea
and you save that pawn with g4 right
yeah if queen d5 i can play osg forward
i mean first of all knight d3 93 first
yes and i can always play g4 later so
responding is very strong
um
so he decided to go on the five take on
b4
and uh
it's 93 it looks pretty normal we should
d7 we should be four
yeah and this here i was really happy
with my position i wasn't i was okay i'm
maybe a super happy overstatement
because i was worried a little bit about
the phone before which is could be an
issue in long-term perspective it's
probable only five will be of course
winning position nearly but here are
some doubts about this poem before but
on the other hand like it i cannot
really see how can i take my pawn a four
because my bishop only four i can also
play rook a2 rook one maybe play for a5
and pawn b3 also pawn b4 is also not
really going anywhere so i just think
it's it's it's better for white and here
he played with g4 which i think was a
big mistake because uh this move it
seemingly is logical because he wants to
play h5 bishop h6 activate this that
bishop on g7 on the other hand it just
weakens the king's side like a lot so i
think after h4 is a really huge huge
advantage okay to an h3
uh yeah 95 first
queen d8 takes if it takes me bishop to
hg4 i play f300 h2 which i think is very
strong yeah the problem is that this is
something on the h file is always coming
yeah something on the h file is strong
yeah king or g2 is so safe
there's absolutely no way in which black
can create anything yeah i mean here i
think it's just
it's
close to winning without just winning
yeah it's it's a plus three already plus
three already okay uh strategically
winning okay
here i was thinking if i can play knight
c7 but i just don't think it's necessary
uh so i just played rouge one
i think he would give you already
yeah if you play knight c7 so i just
played rouge
i'm just gonna put it on the engine
knight c7 yeah it doesn't work probably
it will it it does not work it doesn't
work that's what i thought okay good
enough well enough that it doesn't work
oh my god that was tempted please don't
thank you
okay working one rookie one uh yeah so
crook h8 and now now that xb6 works now
this works because queen b6 bishop a
drug a queen e5 and then i play uh rook
takes h6 on anything and checkmate yeah
because it's just going to be and it's
just queen f7
yeah
all right so you played rookie sam but
this is pretty much over uh we do have a
draw kind of expected that draw between
sam hanin and robert hungaski in that
completely complicated queen end game
that ended up with a black player with
an extra pawn but no real chances and
that finishes the big group and that
that finishes the b group we are only
two games left uh we'll go back to them
but
yeah this is just hopeless and it was it
was a pretty checkmate at the end yeah
it's very picturesque yeah five okay one
this was nice
darius you mentioned a big event for you
what is next for you uh final four yes
this one actually remembers yeah who
knows
we asked him what's your next tournament
he said i don't know something in me
[Laughter]
uh final four in
april right april 2nd and 3rd in lubbock
texas yeah well we're definitely looking
forward to your games uh what does this
tournament uh the spring chess classic
the full chess classic what did this
tournament uh mean for you
um
they
i don't know how to answer this question
but they are basically
just amazing that they are here i enjoy
playing every single of them every
single one of them so uh i'm really
grateful for the english club for
organizing them and
yeah i hope and i wish i can get invited
in the future too well thank you very
much daryus we're looking forward to
your next few tournaments thank you
certainly making a name for himself and
what plus to score is a good reason to
invite him to the next one no doubt
about that is surging in the rankings as
we mentioned a very tough field here at
uh in the top 10 of the us championships
darius is